là je réalise que je suis toujours en
vie réalise ensuite que j'ai essayé de
tuer quelqu'un c'est pas facile à
conscientiser
notre invité du samedi 20h ce soir
Maxime brunnery bonsoir alors le 14
juillet 2002 vous étiez arrêté sur les
Champs-Élysées après avoir tenté
d'assassiner le président de la
République Jacques Chirac puis essayez
de vous suicider aujourd'hui vous
publiez chez de Noël une vie ordinaire
je voulais tuer Jacques Chirac vous
expliquez sans concession votre dérive
politique et psychologique on en reparle
à 20h
[Musique]
Maxime brunneret rebonsoir vous êtes né
le 21 mai 1977 père agent de maîtrise la
snekma mère informaticienne dans la
grande distribution vous grandissez à
Courcouronnes dans l'Essonne et vous
dites l'ennui à l'état chimiquement pur
c'était la vie disons direct la au
niveau familial matériellement j'ai
jamais manqué de rien mais bon sinon
votre père était un personnage assez
transparent qui laissait votre mère tout
gérer à la maison
votre mère est une mère castratrice
dites-vous et paranoïaque ce sera disait
comment
le droit de rien faire par peur du Condy
râteau tout simplement Nicolas vous
vivez cloitré dans votre chambre en fait
voilà c'est ça vous dites à la maison il
y a pas de conversation c'était le
silence quoi couvert par le bruit de la
télévision
à 15 ans vous êtes un adolescent chétif
couvert d'acné révolté et c'est là que
votre révolte va trouver le moyen de
s'exprimer un jour vous découvrez sur
Arte un reportage sur des groupuscules
néonazis en Europe défilé de skinhead je
crois Celtic et cette jeunesse bravant
réellement les interdits vous séduit en
fait oui parce qu'elle brave les vrais
interdits et le véritable interdit moral
c'est de dire faut pas être raciste faut
pas être fasciste mais moi je le suis et
je t'emmerde voilà donc là vous devenez
le le petit facho provocateur quoi 1m80
c'est pas petit alors l'idéologie
néonazi va vous permettre d'être en
opposition avec la terre entière donc là
d'un seul coup vous traduisez votre
révolte et là vous commencez par le foot
vous devenez un ultra du PSG les soirs
de match vous pouvez enfin défouler
l'énergie et la haine qui est en vous en
fait
contre contre les CRS ainsi que un cycle
au complet supporter adverse le tout
baignant dans plusieurs hectolites de
bières
alors à 17 ans vous entamez votre
construction idéologique vous lisez de
Rio la recherche brasillac Céline et
vous transformer votre chambre en musée
un petit peu de la Révolution
nationaleiste quoi la chambre que
j'avais appelé
mon bunker mon équipe de vous dire qu'au
mur son pas des icônes républicaines et
démocrates qui qui figure et au niveau
littéraire j'étais beaucoup marqué par
Pierre riollard Rochelle d'une part pour
profond désire européens son côté
sulfureux et son côté désespérés aussi
et vos parents ils disent quoi quand
vous commencez à mettre des posters ou
des emblèmes néo-nazis dans votre
chambre pas grand chose pas grand chose
on s'en foutent rien du tout j'ai eu 18
ans je fais ce que je veux et c'est tout
alors à 21 ans vous tournez le dos à la
tribune de Boulogne vous passez du foot
à la politique et vous devenez trésorier
d'un petit groupe de skins qui s'appelle
3B bière baise et baston avec t-shirt à
croix celtique paraboots fringues
anglaise et marteau de Thor autour du
cou crâne rasé donc là vous devenez
quand même une espèce de caricature de
néonazi
toute la panoplie et baigner dans la
surenchère et dans la violence qu'elle
soit verbale verbale ou physique et vous
faites quoi avec ces potes de 3B
principalement boire provoquer elle
hommage de foot se rendre dans les
concerts
j'ai envie de dire aussi peut-être
chasser une certaine forme d'enduit
assez profond le problème c'est que dans
les 3B il y a un B qui manque c'est la
base quand même ouais parce que j'ai
pris avec le temps c'est quand on a
quand on a besoin de deux on gagne le 3e
tout simplement alors vos parents en
fait il vous posent toujours pas de
question en voyant ça et là vous entrez
au parti nationaliste français européen
le PNFE là c'est la marge de la marge
quoi c'est à dire c'est à la droite du
Front national encore ça non là je pense
ce qui avait pire puisque même pour le
Front national on passait vraiment pour
des dangereux alors le slogan c'est
parti c'est France d'abord blanche
toujours oui c'est ça là vous participez
à la cérémonie du solstice d'été de la
Saint-Jean donc à côté de Beauvais dans
un parc
vous mangez du sanglier vous buvez de
l'hydromel et là vous rencontrez des
ex-mahan SS nostalgie du Troisième Reich
le penfone les skins sont fait nostalgie
d'une époque qui n'ont pas connu
là j'ai vu l'occasion de rencontrer ce
que j'avais vu dans le livre d'histoire
quelques années avant au fur et à mesure
de la conversation ah oui bah en fait
c'était un volontaire SS français qui
s'est battu dans la diffusion jusqu'à
Moscou dans la division Charlemagne
c'est assez assez particulier comme
rencontre
vous êtes content finalement de
participer à cette fête parce que vous
dites j'étais enfin accepté quelque part
quoi voilà je suis accepté dans un
groupe je peux parler de mes lectures
avec d'autres personnes donc Céline
Drieu brasillac etc il y a aussi le côté
vraiment interdit quoi qu'est-ce que tu
as fait ce week-end j'étais une
cérémonie au nazie bah tes conneries si
si c'est vrai ça existe mais est-ce que
est-ce que vous y croyez à cette
idéologie là le dieu Thor le soleil
tue-les je pense que c'est de la reine
de la rêverie adolescente en 1998 quand
le PNFE disparaît vous songez à
rejoindre le Front National et vous les
trouvez un peu ridicule finalement vous
trouvez qu'ils sont un peu Catteau
tradique quoi complètement anachronique
un acronyme vieux chiant alors en fait
vous entrez au guide voilà c'est une
association étudiante
oui on va dire ça comme ça
et puis ensuite vous entrez au MNR le
nouveau parti de Bruno Maigret dissident
du Front national là vous avez une vraie
activité au parti de Maigret là bon j'ai
envie de j'ai envie de faire carrière
donc on se voit déjà avec des
responsabilités locales on se met à
prendre des sections oui vous propose de
vous présenter un moment voilà oui
candidat donc municipales à Paris et
puis un jour vous êtes rattrapé par la
réalité en fait votre vie est un désert
amoureux et sentimental vous êtes dingue
d'une militante qui s'appelle Virginie
mais quand vous l'approchez à la peur de
Maxime Le barjot Maxime Le psycho
dites-vous et là la névrose la psychose
même vous guette quoi bah là c'est
là c'est
de la souffrance insoutenable et donc
vous vous rendez compte que finalement
ben voilà à quoi vous avez jamais baisé
c'est pas avec elle que vous avez baisé
en tous les cas tout à fait peut-être un
côté très flamme
je me rends compte que ça ce sera
impossible avec elle j'en veux pas
d'autres donc
grosse frustration sexuelle on peut dire
ça
et c'est là que vous décidez de vous
suicider mais vous dites il est pas
question que je parle sur la pointe des
pieds avant de me flinguer je vais faire
quelque chose quoi je vais faire un acte
et donc vous décidez de tuer le
président Jacques Chirac avant de vous
tuer voilà oui alors là vous commencez
par craquer tout votre pognon en
fringues en Palace vous payez une
escort-girl ukrainienne avec qui j'ai
pas eu on va dire je peux plus consommer
si c'était passé quelque chose ça aurait
pu vous finalement vous ouvrir sur
d'autres aspects de la vie
alors
rien du tout parce qu'en même temps
est-ce que c'est vraiment de l'amour je
ne pense pas alors là vous achetez un 22
long rifle et vous allez vous entraîner
dans un bois près de Corbeil-Essonnes
vous entraînez beaucoup une après-midi
pas plus pas plus et le jour J le 14
juillet vous levez tôt vous rasez prenez
une douche vous habillez avec soin et
vous partez avec votre 22 Long Rif dans
la voiture que vous avez loué pour
l'occasion direction Paris en écoutant
pas une petite blague des Rolling Stones
Stones j'aurais pu être sympathie for
the devil aussi c'est vrai
alors là vous vous garez aux Invalides
vous prenez le métro jusqu'à la Porte
Maillot parce que toutes les stations
des Champs-Élysées sont fermées pour des
raisons de sécurité en sortant du métro
Porte Maillot vous allez dans une
boulangerie vous achetez un croissant un
jus d'orange
et là quand même vous prenez un peu pour
Ravaillac comprenez un peu pour lire
vosval oui c'est ça ça fait une sorte de
lierre vhébronnerie
alors Chirac apparaît vous visez vous
tirez
personne ne réagit personne n'empêchait
de tirer par contre faut que le coup de
fait partie elle a la réaction là vous
retournez l'arme contre vous est-ce que
est-ce que s'il y avait pas eu des gens
qui interviennent est-ce que vous
l'auriez vraiment fait est-ce que vous
aviez le courage de le faire oui j'ai
pas trouvé j'ai pas trouvé la gâchette
donc si on enlève si on enlève les
badauds qui qui me met au sol je suis
précis pour vous parler aujourd'hui
tout est relatif mais en prison ce que
j'ai fréquenté surtout les le plus gros
de la population et là pour viol faut
savoir que c'est dix ans pas plus et
effectivement on est au niveau du temps
effectif c'est 5 ans et quelques donc on
a moi je dis pour un truc qui fait zéro
mort zéro blessé 0 dégât matériel par
rapport à la vie d'une femme qui est
complètement gâchée
moi je veux dire personnellement je
trouve que ma peine je l'ai accepté je
l'ai fait j'ai accompli je suis pas
senti en conditionnel par principe je
suis allé jusqu'au bout j'avais pas mal
me tenir en prison pour faire mes 10 ans
jusqu'au bout et à côté de ça vu ce qui
ce qui m'a touché
ce qui a touché quelqu'un qui mettrait
proche personnellement ça fait vraiment
mon livre moi je suis pour la
réhabilitation de la peine de mort pour
la criminels sexuel ni plus ni moi
alors en prison vous recevez la visite
de votre mère qui vous dit tu es mieux
ici que dehors ouais
texto donc
c'est un peu dur ouais et vos parents
vous les voyez plus maintenant j'ai mis
une distance
vous avez appris quoi en prison
j'ai appris quoi j'ai appris un métier
j'embêté les assistantes de gestion j'ai
appris à organiser un festival celtique
qui a eu lieu dans la prison ainsi qu'en
dehors je trouvais ça pas mal
j'ai appris à compter sur moi-même aussi
et pas me remettre à me remettre aux
autres
selon ce qu'ils sont en tant qu'individu
pas selon ce qu'ils sont dans un groupe
racial religieux politique sexuel en
tant qu'individu alors vous avez écrit
au président Jacques Chirac pour lui
demander pardon et vous a pas répondu
non Jacques Chirac j'espère qu'il me
répondra un jour
alors dans ces mémoires en fait il dit
qu'il a rien remarqué ce jour-là
c'est pas un peu décevant pour vous non
pas vraiment vous avez vous avez honte
de ce que vous avez fait
vis-à-vis de moi-même oui mais j'ai pas
présenté d'excuses vis-à-vis j'ai envie
de dire du public puisqu'ils n'ont pas
été touchés j'ai purgé ma peine de
prison j'ai présenté des excuses formes
d'une lettre privée à la victime le
reste du monde si ça leur plaît pas
c'est j'ai envie de dire j'ai pas j'ai
pas de compte à rendre au grand public
quoi mon livre c'est pas c'est pas mais
un couple pas c'est pas le moins d'un
fasciste j'ai dit ce que je pensais
franchement j'ai des regrets quand même
oui oui ça par contre sur la conscience
j'ai essayé de quelqu'un ça ça je
l'oublie pas
Claude
comme ça
c'est une sorte de néant qui relève de
la psychothérapie 10000 comme ça c'est
dangereux il faut les combattre non si
on a la malchance de croiser
des individus comme ça qui sont à la à
la dérive totalement ils peuvent briser
des des grands destins et c'est ces
troublants c'est fascinant et c'est
terrifiant quoi moi ce que je trouve
terrifiant c'est la psychothérapie vous
savez ce que c'est en prison c'est du
cacheton à mort on teste des nouvelles
molécules sur les détenus bon si ça vous
plaît tant mieux moi j'ai arrêté en
douce donc ils ont cru même espèce de
trucs judiciaire qui m'ont collé pendant
15 mois après ma sortie quand encore je
prenais des cachets j'en ai pas pris
donc en quoi comme quoi ça fonctionne
pas leur truc enfin c'est la fumisterie
c'est tout c'est vraiment du foutage de
gueule
écoutez Thierry moi je
suis assez
par ce récit par cette vie je n'ai pas
mesuré comment une enfance
malheureuse un enfant abandonné pouvait
dériver à ce point et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu